>>> ON TOP OF ALL THE THINGS
THIS SERIES REPRESENTS, IT IS
THE FIRST FIRST-ROUND SERIES
THAT LeBRON JAMES HAS LOST IN
HIS CAREER.
McKINNIE WILL SHOOT.
BY THE WAY, WE HAVE JUST BEEN
TOLD THAT BOOKER WAS NOT
EJECTED.
INITIALLY IT LOOKED AS IF HE
WERE GOING TO BE EJECTED.
ONLY CROWDER WAS.
REGARDLESS, THAT'S IT.
THAT'S WHY BOOKER IS ON THE
BENCH.
CAN CELEBRATE WITH HIS
TEAMMATES, SEASON HIGH 47.
HE HIT EIGHT THREES.
AND THE PHOENIX SUNS HAVE GONE
ON THE ROAD AFTER MISSING THE
PLAYOFFS FOR 11 CONSECUTIVE
YEARS AND BEATEN THE DEFENDING
CHAMPION ON THEIR HOME COURT IN
THE FIRST ROUND.
AND NOW THEY'LL TAKE ON THE
DENVER NUGGETS IN ROUND TWO.
THAT SHOULD BE A BEAUTY.
>> Kevin: DOESN'T GET MUCH
EASIER AT ALL.
GIVE CREDIT TO THE SUNS.
11 YEARS AGO LOST TO THIS SAME
FRANCHISE, THE LAKERS, IN GAME
6.
GETTING BACK INTO THE POST
SEASON, BEATING THE DEFENDING
CHAMPIONS, ADVANCING.
GOT TO GIVE CREDIT TO MONTY
WILLIAMS.
THIS TEAM IS ON ITS WAY TO MEET
A WORTHY OPPONENT IN THE DENVER
NUGGETS.
>> Kevin: THEY HAVE WON 44 OF
THEIR LAST 58 GAMES.
THERE'S JASON KENT TALKING WITH
CHRIS PAUL.
TWO OF THE GREATEST POINT GUARDS
IN THE HISTORY OF THE NBA.
CHRIS PAUL HAS TAKEN HIS TEAM TO
THE SECOND ROUND.
PHOENIX, THE NUMBER TWO SEED,
HAS BEATEN THE SEVEN SEED LOS
ANGELES LAKERS